you don't like watching yourself if
you're in a dramatic role but I love
watching myself through comedy comedy
you're innately making fun of yourself
it's it's very liberating the more
ridiculous you look the more successful
you are but in a serious role yeah
nobody likes to see himself or herself
up on screen you all remember the first
time you ever saw yourself you've
completely freaked out no actor
completely overcomes that and the more
serious you are the more embarrassed so
I avoid myself when I'm serious but I
secretly watch third Rock from the Sun
okay what about you Mel do you like to
watch yourself on on screen it does make
you kind of wriggly I get I get pretty
Wrigley I try not to do it right other
people give me reviews and that doesn't
mean come yeah what about when you're
watching like one of your you know a Mad
Max movie or something from it's a long
time ago does it bring you back to that
time when you see it no it doesn't I
just feel the Arthritis and I harken
back to a time when those things didn't
exist yeah yeah and it was visibly
apparent
you